[Music]
0 Arena
0's last concert, the sacred place for idols
I want you guys to come to the opening of 0 Arena
Ah, the
typhoon is coming Haha
I'm just annoying everyone, pulling my chopsticks red and red If you weren't there
Nanase-san  It was about to be crushed before it became a star Because it's
such an important time,
I'll entrust Hiyori-san with the role of the center
of Aikoshu 7.
Yes, I was relieved
every morning Before I went to work, I was anxious, so
yes,
I'm tired
What can I do as a boss
?  Then you should go higher than
that 1. To torment the idol is
a body with a chair It
's the feeling of the moon
I
wonder what my role will be from now on I
wonder what I can do It doesn't matter how much I spend I love baby faces